il est peut-être derrière les barreaux
mais son état d'esprit lui semble libre
souriant malgré la violence de la peine
Vladimir car amourza écoute le juge ne
prenant visiblement pas au sérieux les
raisons de sa condamnation
la Russie sera libre est-il dit en
levant ces mêmes notés à 41 ans il est
top de 25 années de prison ferme sa
fameuse géniale demeure combative
cette sentence démonte qu'ils ont
tellement peur de lui dit-elle de son
courage de sa bravoure il le déteste
tellement qu'ils veulent l'emprisonner
pendant un quart de siècle
dérange depuis longtemps virulent en
critique de Vladimir Poutine et de la
guerre en Ukraine il est considéré comme
un ennemi de
l'États en 2015 et 2017 il aura vu
l'assassinat de son mentor l'opposant
politique Boris nepsov en 2015
malgré tout Vladimir car amourza
retourne régulièrement travailler à
Moscou lors d'un de ses séjours la
journaliste Amara altérés
peut être arrêté à tout moment on
connaît des risques aujourd'hui il est
condamné pour autre trahison diffusion
de fausses informations sur l'armée
russe et travaille illégal pour une
organisation indésirable avec pour seul
preuve avancé ses discours
d'un sombre tournant dit l'ambassadrice
canadienne vladimir karamuzza est un
homme d'honneur un défenseur des droits
civiques et un allié d'une Russie
démocratique
d'un gouvernement est un acte de
faiblesse il ambassadrice américaine
Moscou déplore ce qu'ils appellent
l'ingérence des diplomates étrangers
les Vladimir caramosa aurait une santé
fragile il souffre de polyneuropathie et
de pathologies neuromusculaires à la
suite des deux empoisonnements
la polyneuropathie conduit à la
paralysie dit sa femme je réalise qu'il
ne lui reste même pas 5 ans à vivre
encore moins 25
il reste un des derniers dissidents
politiques en Russie son seul regret
selon ses proches ne pas avoir réussi à
convaincre plus de compatriotes du
danger que pose le Kremlin pour la
Russie et pour le monde entier ici
Radio-Canada Washington